i did want to congratulate jason who
works for us he's lost
53 pounds in fact but matt who works for
us
saw jason and he said it was really
startling
look at jason's face see i know
stand up let me see what you're doing
let me see i can't see how i look in
this hole
can you can you see that belly's down
look at that
wow 53 pounds dude you know he's like a
he's a fat guy who doesn't want to get
rid of the clothes
that he was wearing when he was fatter
because it shows off his weight loss
because will saw jason as well and
jason's none of jason's clothes fit and
phil told me
he looks like the kid in big remember
when tom hanks
that's right when he shrunk yeah will
the clothes are uh startling right he's
like wrapping the bat the belt around
his waist twice like it's so much
it looks ridiculous like just go buy a
new pair of pants
jason why not or do you not have faith
in yourself like do you think you're
going backwards or something no i have
too much faith i'm in the middle of a
journey right now so i don't want to
you know go out buy a whole bunch of new
clothes and then in two months i hope to
be
you know even thinner and and need new
clothes then but it was also super nice
not having seen anybody for or you know
well over a year
to get all the you know it's it's you
know when you see me day to day it's
like oh okay nice it looks like you're
losing weight but i got a lot of nice
uh reactions when i saw everyone there i
am learning so much about my
relationship with food during this
entire thing it wasn't like something
like
my stomach just i just couldn't eat
because someone made my stomach small it
made me really realize that i was
looking at every meal as an opportunity
to celebrate
and you know make myself feel better and
i was eating too fast and
i had this very little kid attitude of
like well i'm an adult and if i want to
have three cheeseburgers for mcdonald's
you know who could tell me no and blah
blah blah and they've
you know i really i'm trying to be you
he came to my house he only had one
slice of pizza i was very impressed
that's impressive discipline yeah
portion control that's what you're
talking about portion control
i counted out the chips at will's house
he had a bowl of chips i counted out
four which was a serving size
and that's all i had and i just sat
there and ate them slowly you know
instead of
howard i used to leave food we used to
just randomly leave food on jason's desk
just to see if he would eat it when he
came back he never questioned anything
whatever we left on his desk
what was the worst thing well that you
can remember there like what would you
leave i mean it was just like
nobody can't like open candy you'd be
like he has no idea where this came from
like
right there you could poison yourself
what was the worst thing the mcdonald's
cheeseburger i just came back
from somewhere else and it was a
mcdonald's cheeseburger just sitting on
my desk and i'm looking around i'm like
okay
you want ralph commenting on your diet i
mean uh why not he comments on
everything
what has he got to say you know here's
here's the thing
don't call it a journey i hate that
[ __ ] expression everything's a
journey now
you lost away it's not a [ __ ] journey
stop it oh my god
everybody everything is so important i
mean if you do something you just did it
i mean it's not a journey
i'd like to write about that journey can
be annoying you're right i apologize for
the
the journey apparently you are learning
things about yourself that's whatever
you want
i don't think you have done ever ralph
learn something about yourself
i do have one question do you shave your
neck
no i mean i shaved this part usually but
not uh but it looks like you there's a
nice little circle here
do you shave do i shave regularly no i
shave regularly down to like the bottom
of my neck
yeah you that looks silly
yeah you got too much you look like a
wolf like he's one of those guys his
beard goes right into his chest hair
yeah his body hair connects from his
face to his
feet he's got a lot of body here
we're going to work on that next that's
the big prize
i just don't even know what's going on
here see robin that's a big prize i lose
all this weight and then i'm still
covered in body hair
[Laughter]
by the way we're working on a uh sexy
jason kaplan calendar for 2022.
all for charity yes
you